[Music]  you worried about darius hoping your  dreams  go oh  boy hit him again i'm so sorry  you bounce your head back when my two  inches from your body why do you why's  it so hard to make a hit jesus oh my god  you're running  come on let me go back to that line  about darius cause i can't wait for  another walloping all right here we go  oh wait uh oh cameron um  is your hand okay  all right um okay uh uh so you you go up  and then i say darren okay great okay  darius is finally not haunting my dreams  no way i'm i'm out  if it makes you feel any better i cannot  eat gelato either right it doesn't make  me feel better i don't care i am lactose  intolerance right  wow that happens to uh i think  wow that's not normal whatever that was  i mean that is years old whatever just  i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna go  i can hear you giggling patrick  hold on  that's perfectly normal  [Music]  but that that's what i'm talking about  that is  an  ancient evil whatever that is  [Music]